プログラミングモデルとは、定義を行う基本的な仕様です
ソフトウェアの構造
と実行方法を定め、フレームワークを提供します
開発者がアルゴリズムを表現するための
コードを整理するためのもので、低レベルの詳細を抽象化します
基盤となるハードウェアや実行環境の
さまざまなモデルは、異なる種類の問題に適しています
ハードウェアアーキテクチャもさまざまで
抽象化のレベルも異なります
この章では
量子と古典のプログラミングモデルを見ていきます
そしてそれらを組み合わせてアルゴリズムを実行する方法を確認します
ハイブリッド環境で
まずはプログラミングモデルから始めましょう
量子コンピュータ向けの基本的なプログラミングモデルとして
ほぼすべての量子開発者に馴染みのある
quantum circuitがあります。詳細には立ち入りません
quantum circuitの詳細については
すでに多くの優れたリソースがあるためです
Joan Watersによる講義も含まれています
ここでは、circuitがワイヤーと呼ばれる線で構成されており
qubitを表すことだけ触れておきます
また、量子状態への操作を表すgateと
測定のセットがあります
もう一つの重要なプログラミングモデルの概念は
primitiveです
primitiveは、量子コンピュータで最もよく使われるタスクを表します
ユーザーが量子コンピュータで実現しようとする
現在、2つのprimitiveが利用可能です
SamplerとEstimatorです。Samplerは
quantum circuitで準備した状態をサンプリングできます
Estimatorは、期待値を推定できます
observableの期待値を、量子circuitで準備した状態について
circuitの最後の概念として
このセクションで取り上げるのは
transpilationです。transpilation
とは、入力されたcircuitを変換するプロセスで
特定の量子デバイスのトポロジーに合わせます
デバイス上での実行のために
ノイズのある量子コンピュータでの実行向けに
古典コンパイラと同様に
transpilerのルーティンは段階的に
circuitの構造を変換します。一連のpassを適用することで
では、古典のプログラミングモデルについて話しましょう
古典コンピュータには多くのプログラミングモデルがありますが
古典コンピュータ向けの
この章では2つに絞って説明します
最もよく使われる並列プログラミングと
タスクワークフローです。この2つのモデルを使うことで
量子プログラミングモデルと組み合わせることで
あらゆるハイブリッドを表現できます
どんな複雑さの量子古典ワークフローでも
並列プログラミングモデルは
プログラムを同時に実行できるサブ問題に分割します
並列プログラミングには2つの主なパラダイムがあります
共有メモリ並列処理と分散メモリ並列処理です
ここでは分散メモリモデルに焦点を当てましょう
分散メモリモデルは
独立したプロセスを別々のコアで実行します
またはノードで、各プロセスは独自のメモリを持ちます
通信はメッセージパッシングで行われます
知っておくと便利な概念がいくつかあります
最初はプロセスです
別々のコアで実行されるプログラムの独立したインスタンスです
別々のコアで動作します
次にランクです。プロセスの一意な識別子です
そして、単一プログラム
複数データという抽象化モデルがあります
これは抽象化モデルで
プログラムの単一インスタンスが複数のノードに配布される計算です
複数のノードに分散されます
ソースコードは同じですが
各ノードのデータは異なります
並列プログラミングモデルでの実行は
以下のように行われます
単一プログラムが複数のノードに配布され
複数の並列プロセスが開始されます
プログラムの制御フローはランクによって決まります
つまり、プロセスの識別子によって
通信は
メッセージパッシングを通じて行われます
タスクワークフロープログラミングモデルは
計算をグラフまたはDAGとして抽象化します
グラフの各ノードは特定のタスクです
またはジョブで、エッジは依存関係やデータを示します
具体的な例はドキュメントに記載されています
量子コンピューティングでよく語られる一連の処理
マッピング、最適化
実行、後処理は
タスクワークフロープログラミングモデルです
すべてのタスクが順番に実行されます
パイプラインの中で一つずつ
ただしタスクワークフローでは
順次実行に縛られることはありません
タスクを並列で実行することもできます
各タスクやワークフローは、それ自体が並列ジョブになれます
ですから、これらのモデルを組み合わせて
任意のアルゴリズムを記述できます
どんな複雑さのものでも。
学んだ概念をコードに適用してみましょう
まず、並列プログラミングパラダイムを使ってシンプルな Hello World を試します
並列プログラミングのパラダイムを使って
Open MPIを使用します
これはMPIプロトコルの実装で
並列プログラミングにおける
メッセージパッシングの標準です
まず、プログラムを用意する必要があります
ここでは mpi4py を使っています
PythonのバインディングMPIです
MPIのPythonバインディングで、ランクを使ってプログラムの
制御フローを決めているのがわかります
では、サブミッションスクリプトを確認しましょう。
2つのノードを使用する設定になっています
normalパーティションでノードあたり1タスク
プログラムを実行してみます。少し待って
ジョブの結果を確認できます
プログラムのログ出力が確認できます
2つのノードと2つのプロセスを使っています
ランクで識別されます
出力を見るとわかるように
ランク0とランク1が制御フローを決めています
プログラムの制御フローを決定します
ランク0のプロセスが送信したのがわかります
ランク1のプロセスへのペイロードを
ランク1のプロセスがそれを受信しました
次にタスクワークフローについても説明します
ワークロード管理システムと呼ばれる
ツールがあります。これらは特別に設計されており
複雑なワークフローを実行するためのものです
ただし、複雑にしすぎないよう、Slurmの組み込み
依存関係機能を使います
計算グループを構築するために
まず、ワークフローのタスクを用意します
これは同じコードです
各タスクを分けることのメリットは
マッピング、最適化、実行
後処理を別々のステップとして持てることです
各タスクに固有のリソース要件を指定できます
例えば、マッピング、最適化
後処理は必要ありません
量子リソースへのアクセスが
そのため、古典パーティションで実行できます。
一方、実行タスクには
量子リソースが必要なため、量子
パーティションで実行します。
依存関係機能を使ってタスクを繋いでみましょう
ワークフローに連結します。
まだ実行中です
sbatchコマンドに--parsableフラグをつけて実行し
ジョブIDを返してもらいます
そのジョブIDを渡すことができます
他のタスクへの依存関係として
ご覧のように、ジョブを実行しています
依存関係を持つワークフローの中で
ワークフロー全体が完了したら、結果を確認できます。
ご覧のように、期待値が返ってきています。
また、すべての
各ステップの結果も確認できます。
こちらにも表示されています。
以上で、プログラミングモデルのセクションは終わりです
次の章では、応用的な
アルゴリズムについて説明します